sign with the Phoenix Suns they gave me  a check for twenty five thousand dollars  cash blew it all in one day I blew it  all in one day me and Mike Bibby went to  the mall and bought everything we could  find I think when I got back to the  house I probably had maybe four or five  thousand dollars that was my first check  I signed my six year deal the Pacers  first thing I did was bought my mom and  my grandmother house it took me about  six years of my career to understand how  to even think about generational wealth  that word never even came around nobody  in my family ever thought about saying  generational wealth it took me being  around people and having financial  advisors six seven years in my career to  start thinking about aiming for a rainy  day